زاد المنخفض الجوي من معاناه الاف
العائلات النازحه شمال غربي سوريا خصوصا
في المخيمات العشوائيه التي تغيب فيها
شبكات الصرف الصحي وتفتقر الى ادنى مقومات
العيش الكريم تساقط الامطار خلال الساعات
الماضيه ادى الى انتشار الوحل والطين في
ازقه المخيمات وايضا الى تشكل برك المياه
الاثنه يعتمد النازحون في تامين الدفء
لاطفالهم على ما يجمعونه من اغصان الزيتون
يجهزونها بحزم صغيره ليتم حرقها في مدافع
بدائيه هي ايضا بعض مما يجمعونه من
البلاستيك من مكبات النفايات القريبه من
هنا هذه المدافئ البدائيه تتسبب بامراض
تنفسيه خصوصا عند الاطفال الرضع وكبار
السن مع طول امد النزوح وتكرار الماساه مع
كل شتاء بدا النازحون يناشدون الدولي
بايجاد حل جذري لمعاناتهم وهي تامين عوده
كريمه الى مدنهم وبلداتهم وارزاقهم على
امل ان يتخلصوا من هذه المعاناه التي تكرر
في كل عام ادهم ابو الحسام الجزيره